alone in Yokohama this is not the
honeymoon Alan steel had been planning
for most of the past fortnight he's been
in isolation in a Japanese hospital
after contracting coronavirus on the
Diamond Princess cruise ship this
stretch of water now separates him from
his wife Wendy who's still on board that
was my biggest worry 70 Wendy on her own
to be honest you've been doing better
than I thought she would a lot better
in reality you were taking off the
cruise left you I've taken to hospital
what's going through your head when
you're on solitary confinement in prison
I have no no symptoms whatsoever
none so I it's unfair to me to say I've
seen the pictures and if people are
dying of it but my personal thing I've
had no symptoms that's suppose really
I'm just a carrier well the six hundred
people on this ship have now tested
positive for coded 19 today authorities
confirmed to Japanese patients in their
80s with existing health issues have
died the government's defended the way
it's managed quarantine on board saying
thorough action to prevent the spreads
been taken but Alan skeptical the
quarantine process was a joke
oh it's a joke the Kuantan people and
the crew actually spread it
yeah I do I think they make I don't
saying they didn't start it but I think
they'd be exacerbated the problem yes
hello
we had your results as passengers
continued disembarking wendy is still
waiting to get you all clear that needs
to happen before Friday night when the
British evacuation flight is due to
leave the Britons on the ship have been
desperately counting down the days to
evacuation whilst still fearing
infection because anyone who test
positive even at the last minute cannot
get on the plane home this quarantine
facility on the where'll is where
returning Britons will spend the next 14
days while Allen's keen to get home
he thinks the UK government's we've been
slow to act I know poor Boris this
giri's ansvil is not brexit reshuffling
his cabin the floods so I suppose the 78
Brits what hell do they matter is that
how you feel that they forgot you oh yes
well the government's are treated as
pretty badly McAllister by the weekend
all passengers who tested negative
should be off this ship and heading home
finally able to put the coronavirus
crews behind them
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Japan